why coyote and not wolf there's actually
a good reason for that and what's the
deal with Bob there's more to the call
signs in Top Gun Maverick than you think
while Ed Harris's Admiral Kane is only
briefly on screen he makes his presence
felt initially entering Captain Pete
Maverick Mitchell's life as the man
trying to shut down the test Pilot's
project to perfect a jet capable of
flying Mach 10. he seemingly gets
outplayed Maverick gets off the ground
before Kane's arrival and hits mach 10
successfully while Kane can do nothing
more but observe from the command center
unfortunately Maverick's success is
short-lived as he loses control of the
aircraft and crashes rather
spectacularly still Mitchell's Guardian
Angel former rival turned friend Admiral
Tom Iceman kazanski intercedes on
Maverick's behalf Iceman gets his friend
gig training young Pilots for A
Dangerous Mission at Top Gun Academy
delaying Maverick's honorable discharge
once again you get yourself in trouble
Iceman makes a call and you're back in
the air despite his foiled plans it's
still easy to see how Kane earned his
call sign Hammer he's a man who strikes
fast and efficiently his presence makes
an immediate impact that is impossible
to miss or ignore so while Maverick may
have gotten lucky this time it's clear
Kane is a man who usually hits his
Target and eliminates them in one clean
stroke initially John Hamm's Admiral
Simpson seems a strange figure to where
the call signs Cyclone immediately
skeptical of Maverick Cyclone presents
as a serious man who makes tough
decisions but has no use for risks or
flaunting the rules everything about
their interactions makes it clear that
Cyclone is waiting for Maverick to fail
from the moment the captain pulls up a
Top Gun on his motorcycle however as the
film progresses there are hints of how
Cyclone earned his call sign for one the
audience learns that he was number one
in his Top Gun class in addition the
film's emphasis on Instinct and doing
the right thing over the prescribed
method suggests that Cyclone didn't
always grip the rulebook quite so hard
second Cyclone eventually relents
despite the idea that including Maverick
in the mission seems like a significant
risk he makes the call to let Captain
Mitchell lead it additionally he chooses
Maverick strategy for the mission over
his own Cyclone may be a stickler these
days but there are obviously still some
wild wins in his art as the other
Admiral overseeing command of the film's
training and Mission viewers never get
to see baits in the cockpit of a fighter
jet however given his leadership style
there's plenty of evidence as to what
earned him the call sign warlock for one
warlock implies a certain wisdom or
access to information and abilities that
not just everyone has given his
Ascension in the ranks of the Navy it
seems clear that Admiral Bates must have
been a skilled and intelligent pilot
during his time at the Stick of a
fighter jet he also magically manages to
navigate the complex and none too small
egos of cyclone and Maverick getting
them to work together no matter how
strenuously they object to doing so that
kind of interpersonal spell casting
earns you the call sign Warlock
Chief Warrant Officer Coleman comes over
from the scramjet program with Maverick
to Aid in the film's mission having
worked with Maverick for some time
Coleman is the captain's biggest booster
from the start the one person besides
Iceman who seems to believe that
Mitchell is the right man for the job
while no specific reason for the warrant
officer's call sign up Hondo ever comes
up in the movie a look at the words
meaning in other languages offers
significant insights into why he wears
it and wears it well Honshu the largest
island in Japan has historically been
known as Hondo according to Britannica
lending the name a sense of stability
and significance in Spanish meanwhile
Hondo means deep or profound according
to Collins Dictionary Bashir salhuddin's
performance gives Coleman those
qualities whenever he's on screen even
goofing it up during the beach football
game the sincerity of his actions is
apparent his depth of character and
thoroughness are evident throughout the
film too miles teller's Lieutenant
Bradley rooster Bradshaw begins training
as the only young pilot who knows
Maverick in fact the two used to be
quite close Bradshaw is the son of
Maverick's deceased wingman Nick Goose
Bradshaw he's also Maverick's godson
however after Maverick decided rooster
wasn't ready and set the Lieutenant's
progress back years the two had a
falling out and haven't spoken in quite
some time it's no time to be thinking
about the past
obviously the Lieutenant's call sign is
a tribute to his dad maintaining the
Bradshaw family's bird Motif the most
common image of the rooster is that of
the bird whose cry announces mourning
and signals to a farm that it's time to
get to work additionally roosters walk
with a strut that often has a certain
air of arrogance to it being out in
front of the action and doing so with
great confidence are certainly
maverick-esque qualities so
subconsciously you're not Bradshaw's
call sign reveals he is both his
father's son and his Godfather's godson
he's a pilot who has the capacity for
both of their best qualities even if
he's still struggling to find the right
balance between them while decidedly not
the same as Maverick was during his Top
Gun days lieutenants Harrison does in
some ways recreate with rooster the
Maverick Iceman Dynamic saracen is the
Flasher more confident pilot seemingly
more interested in individual Glory
rooster on the other hand shows more
caution perhaps too much and is a far
far better team player as Glenn Powell
the actor who plays lieutenants Harrison
revealed to Cinema Blend the script
featured an even more aggressive call
sign for the lieutenant to match his
antagonistic demeanor however when onset
military Consultants suggested that
Slayer more closely resembled the Air
Force's approach to call signs than the
Navy's Powell rejected it and began to
develop his own working together with
director Joseph Kaczynski and
screenwriter Christopher McQueary the
trio hit on hangman Powell told Jimmy
Kimmel that a specific pilot with the
call sign noose was evidently a
significant inspiration and noose became
hangman the nickname also reflects
erinson's reputation for being only out
for himself if one is out flying with
the Arrogant pilot they should be fully
ready for him to leave them hanging the
moment he has a chance to achieve
individual Glory Monica Barbaro has made
comments suggesting that the call sign
Phoenix doesn't refer to the Arizona
city but actually the mythical bird she
may have even earned the name off camera
bonding with her co-stars during nights
out she told The Hollywood Reporter I
had a pretty intense night of frivolity
we'll say and I Rose From the Ashes the
next day of course the character of
Trace has likely risen from much more
serious ashes than a night out with
colleagues to soar once again and likely
did so on multiple occasions given that
the Navy only began allowing women entry
into the top gun academy in the 90s via
the Washington Post it seems likely that
Trace encountered all types of barriers
on her way to earning her wings in that
light what better call sign could she
have chosen as the owner of the least
badass call sign of them all Lieutenant
Robert Floyd AKA Bob understandably
comes in for some ribbing by his fellow
Pilots I got it baby on board
but no matter how his fellow Pilots
hassle him Floyd seems unshakable a fine
quality to have in a fighter pilot he
chose Bob because that's who he is in
talking to the New York Times Lewis
Pullman who plays Bob also points out
how the call sign acts as a litmus test
for those around him given how others
react to Bob Floyd can Gage what kind of
person and teammate they are while
they're attempting to read him they end
up telling him everything he needs to
know about them
Lieutenant Reuben Fitch's call sign is
as close to a platonic ideal of a
nickname that someone in the armed
forces could ask for but payback isn't
just about taking Revenge Fitch doesn't
want to feel like he owes anyone a favor
for them helping him out in other words
he always pays them back as quickly as
possible Jay Ellis joked with Insider
that he put the name into practice after
playing a prank on co-star Lewis Pullman
as in the film The Watering Hole the
cast frequented had a rule that if your
cell phone was lying on the bar you had
to buy everyone a drink so one night
Ellis got a hold of Pullman's phone and
put it on the bar getting the actor on
the hook for a round of drinks for
everyone in the establishment about a
hundred at the time
[Music]
all right
however like his character's call sign
Ellis made sure to pay Pullman back the
money he spent
a hint to the reasoning behind
Lieutenant Mickey Garcia's call sign can
be seen every time Garcia climbs into a
cockpit like the rest of his fellow
Pilots his call signed Fanboy runs
across the top of the helmet just above
the visor however if one takes a closer
look they'll likely identify as
something that sets his helmet apart the
font real life Fanboys and sci-fi
enthusiasts will likely recognize it
right away while other Pilots have their
names written in a variety of scripts
Garcia's is very specifically the same
font used for the titles on the classic
episodes of Star Trek of course not all
Fanboys are specifically interested in
science fiction or fantasy anyone
enthusiastic about any elements of Pop
Culture can lay claim to the title
Lieutenant machado's call sign of choice
seems like a fantastic name regardless
of backstory much like college mascots
choosing a cool natural predator for a
call sign is an easy move but there's
actually more to it than that as Greg
Davis revealed to comicbook.com he
immediately noticed that Machado chose
coyote as opposed to the bigger canine
Predator the wolf this put the actor in
The mindset that muchado saw himself as
an underdog therefore the pilot likely
acted accordingly working longer and
harder than many of his peers the events
of Top Gun Mavericks seem to Bear out
this interpretation as well during a
critical scene the lieutenant loses
Consciousness due to G-Force pressure
his jet cresting and then beginning a
dead drop towards the ground below the
pilot regains Consciousness far closer
to crashing into the ground than anyone
could be comfortable with and pulls up
just in time it's the kind of thing that
would Shake just about anyone including
fighter pilots nonetheless Machado
recovers and is back at it the next time
the team goes into the air to practice
for the mission like his namesake he's a
scrapper who refuses to go it easily to
understand Admiral Tom kazanski's call
sign viewers need to look back to Val
Kilmer's performance in the original Top
Gun from 1986. in that film kazanski was
always a man of control he largely
maintained his emotions and composure
regardless of the training Mission or
interactions with others as a result he
was cool under pressure for keeping it
under control in and out of the cockpit
the pilot more than earned the call sign
Iceman that composed attitude seems to
have continued after graduating from Top
Gun as a man who projects cool
confidence his demeanor clearly made
others see him as a natural and reliable
leader as a result he ascended to the
rank of vice admiral and served time on
the Joint Chiefs of Staff people like a
man who stays calm Under Pressure to be
in charge and iceman has always been
that viewers also see it in how he
treats Mitchell now kind thoughtful and
still he helps Shepherd his more
emotional friend to the hard but
inevitable decision Maverick must reach
while Tom Cruise's Captain Pete Mitchell
certainly earned his nickname back in
Top Gun the intervening years certainly
don't seem to have changed him much he's
less prone to bursts September than he
was back when viewers first met him but
he remains his stubborn and independent
minded as ever your reputation precedes
you
thank you sir
wasn't a compliment for those unfamiliar
with the military to have served as long
as Mitchell has still be active and only
achieved the rank of Captain is highly
unusual it speaks to him having been
passed over several times for promotion
other characters discussions of him
confirm this is very much the case his
resistance to rules to accepting things
as they are instead of as they could be
ensures he's the best man for the film's
near impossible mission his refusal to
accept conventional wisdom and
acceptable losses leads to him crafting
a plan that wins the day and gets
everyone home alive